when did you start let's see Kennedy got
shot I'm gonna the moon because the moon
it was the greatest day of my life when
we land though a lot of people said we
couldn't do it and we [ __ ] did it
right what a great country that says no
I started acting and stuff because I
went to I did a lot of acting III you
know I started in acting classes and
acting you know and doing plays not in
LA New York I'm in New York I offended I
think Google you you will add you didn't
bro I'm glad you didn't and so you know
acting classes in New York but what here
um let's see 20 when I was about 20 20
or so so in the nineteen forty more or
less how are you I'm 58 okay so so that
was 38 years ago 38 years ago that is
gone by way too quick quick so you did
that and then you were acting in New
York and then you well I first wanted to
do stand-up but I found stand-up when I
was 22 be frightening and I used to
throw up in bathroom stalls before going
out on stage I mean and I used to ask
myself while I'm throwing up I'm like
well why am i doing this if it's yeah
and the answer was and you kept doing it
of course
yeah of course but when I was that age I
was like okay I'm gonna start acting I'm
gonna start get you know because I
always did love theater and and New York
is a theater town you know what I mean
yeah it's a big stand-up town but I love
plays I did Arthur Miller's view from
the review from a bridge I did David
Mamet plays you know all that kind of
[ __ ]
yeah because I was too scared to go out
alone as a stand-up at first I did it
for a while for like six months and then
I pulled back started taking acting and
I did and I did calm
in prom then I started doing one-man
shows then back to stand up and I
finally was like okay I can do stand-up
without throwing up loads so of all the
between Broadway and one-man shows of
all the things stand-up was the most
terrifying by far yeah
Wow for me but you know what I tell
people this were you in the beginning
I'm telling you in the beginning in the
[ __ ] beginning you have to push your
way up onstage yes you have to go you
can do what you have to do it you have
to do it I mean even if you're like in
an open mic and you're up at you know at
2:00 in the morning and it's 10:00 you
have to wait for hours that's still the
internal dialog like you're gonna do it
you have to do it there's no one in the
crowd it doesn't matter you have to do
it but eventually what happens it
happens for everyone instead of getting
pushed you get pulled and when you get
pulled up on stage it's like this I
can't wait to get up there oh yeah I
need to get up there why is this guy up
there oh you mean it evolves in yeah in
a vault it just eventually switches yeah
that's the point where you want to get
to if you're constantly pushing it's not
working out right right but a couple of
years in to three years in you're gonna
wake up and go I have to go up yeah but
it's interesting I think there are
people in you you could tell this to
there are common there are people who
are just it's in their blood to be a
comedian like there's nothing else that
they were meant to do yeah you know what
I mean and then there's people who are
like I'm gonna do stand-up because it's
a good venue for me to be seen and it's
like it's like you know it's an
opportunity instead of someone who just
is I was like a purist what do you love
stand I know but I don't know if I I
don't know if I did it for means to an
end or I don't know if I'm pure well no
you've evolved into I don't know what no
but it's like what is my heart say
[Laughter]
folks I didn't mean to I didn't notice
who's gonna go in this direction I
didn't know there was gonna be an
existential I would be with you it's
like when I look like I'm on a show
coming out an ABC show right I got a
pilot and you are telling me I didn't
get to Montreal it's a I'm not getting
I'm on three things right now [ __ ] face
face you're going in another direction
show me on a few men okay I just want to
go to Montreal that's all but my point
is this is that but so do I do stand-up
so that I can get all these things or am
I in it because when I'll tell you why
when things aren't going well and and
kalila when I met my girlfriend it was
not going well yeah well you were doing
okay I wasn't doing well what did I have
going nothing I'm gonna say this right
now and we see this in the [ __ ] world
all right I believe I said that Theo von
today all right
I believe I wouldn't be wearing that
today with alkali la
I mean don't know I think that small
situation
no I'll tell you why what I'll tell you
why because a couple years ago I had
this audition where it was like 19 pages
of dialogue I didn't memorize I didn't
have it down and we were at NBC I was in
the parking lot and she was in the car
with me and I got I'm not going on yeah
I don't know what bad habit of not
following through so I would have a lot
of these big he lived in the outcomes
that he didn't want to actually work for
and it was they had zero structure I
lived it I lived in the results of
things which like it to me it's like if
I didn't know something backwards and
forwards and memorized that I would
think yeah I'm not gonna get it anyway
so I'm not gonna go in right but she
goes well you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
boom and I go I don't know what you want
me to look like a fool she goes I'd
rather have you look like a fool in
there
and be a man right then be a coward
and we got a huge fight in front of like
in the parking lot in the park so I go
[ __ ] [ __ ] I go [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll
show you that I'm not gonna get so y'all
prove it to you I walked in and I
literally read it like this like I
didn't you know you did this is create
eyes to the page yeah I got it like a
network pilot and then she so what I'm
saying is is that for love I'm on love
right she made me go into love he didn't
want to go they don't like me or you
know I'm in yeah so what I'm saying is
is that she you know four years ago
nothing going on I met her and I just
she's she's giving me the motivation to
go out and fail you know I think you
know when you were a parallel when
you're talking about first doing
stand-up you needed to push yourself
there yeah I'm just pushing you there
and one now you're feeling like you're
you hell no she's the host the show it's
incredible to me like watching it from
such an outsider's perspective because
I've always just been either in a
medical field or always you know I'm I
was a biochemistry major oh so it's nice
to have someone not in industry show but
I've always had at least the discipline
or the structure which was not he works
he's chaotic and that's part of his
appeal but he just needed just the touch
of structure not a lot of structure be
just enough chaotic too and I like that
I think that's what I find attractive
about him yes your wife do that motivate
you
yes yeah you go so what's good you and I
need to be in these relationships yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel like I would
be nothing without her yeah how does it
feel how long have you been married
Eddie four years four
and what we were together seven before
that you met her based on comedy she was
a fan yeah yeah I be she was also a
writer right so she gets it
yes yeah oh yeah she totally gets it
yeah she does not like you're not sexy
the way you said but how because you're
not D'Elia
but right right right no I'm no I'm not
no I'm not I I you know I used to I
don't get offended that much right it's
what you like and me and I can get it go
even further
how hard can i push this yeah I mean
it's like you got a kind of a mr. mu GUI
kind of thing you don't look human fine
with the Daleks fine version of the guy
from op
ah no but what I'm saying is that but
Sochi you you're married
are you backpedaling
[Music]